[Music]
so today we are going to do a deep dive
into our cloud load balancing family on
the global side we have our H CPH TPS
load balancers and our proxies for SSL
and TCP and on the regional we have our
external facing network load balancer
and our internal layer for load
balancing by regional I mean that the
backend instances are constrained to a
specific region and global we can have
back-end instances across multiple
regions it's important to note that
Google cloud load balancing is built on
the same underlying infrastructure that
Google uses to deliver its services to
billions of users daily it also
underpins many of the services that you
use on Google cloud be it storage app
engine kubernetes managed or native so
now by a show of hands how many of you
consider yourselves cloud native come on
yeah cloud native in the house okay and
how many of you consider yourselves
enterprise folks moving to the cloud
awesome I have good news today we're
going to show you how Google cloud load
balancing can help you build
applications that want scale make the
most use of your resources are secure
and optimized for latency and cost we're
going to do this in four parts
we're going to do a deep dive into our
load balancers we're going to secure
your edge we're going to optimize for
latency and cost and ahs it's going to
pull it all together with best practices
so let's get started you know our first
load bouncer was a network load down so
three years ago we published a paper on
maglev and it's are actually in-house
developed software load balancer it runs
on standard Google hardware but they
optimize the code for throughput and
latency and this has been in production
since 2008 and it literally load
balances
all traffic coming into Google's data
centers it also distributes traffic to
our front-end engines located in our
points of presence and now we make them
available to you as our network load
balancer for Google cloud so a network
load balancer essentially load balances
layer for TCP or UDP traffic via hashing
to regional back-end instances the
maglevs tunnel the packet directly to
the back-end instance so the source IP
is preserved the back-end instances
return the packet to the client directly
it's direct server returns so it does
not go through the maglevs in this slide
you see three regional load balancers
test my app and travel what's
interesting is that these regional load
balancers the virtual IP addresses they
come from a regional block but when
you're using the premium tier we
advertise them globally so if Shannon
Singapore wanted to access the load
balancer located in US West my app calm
that traffic would ingress the pop in
Singapore go through our Google global
network and be load balanced at us best
so even though it's a regional load
balancer you have global access with
network load balancing so what's under
the hood remember I was talking about
maglevs so compare and contrast when you
have traditional load balancers they're
typically deployed in an active standby
fashion and they typically need to be
pre warmed to deal with spikes in
traffic that's the one on the Left I
mean yes and on the right you have your
maglevs and these maglevs they're
actually deployed in active active
scale-out fashion the way it works is
that the maglevs
they advertise the virtual IP address of
your load balancers all of them to the
peering router the peering router then
equal cost multi path distributes the
flows to the maglevs
what do you want out of a load balancer
you want to evenly distribute your
workloads
and you want a stable connection from
your client to your back-end instance
and the manga let's do this primarily in
two ways one it does connection tracking
of existing connections so if other
back-end instances come up or go down
your current connection keeps tracked
and stays stable the second it does
something called consistent hashing
which means that regardless of the set
of maglevs changing the backend is
always selected consistently so that's
essentially maglev under the hood so
just to recap what does the network load
balancer get you it's a regional load
balancer you get its alyre full load
balancer you don't get layer seven you
can do two three or five tuple hashing
and it's very performant you get almost
a million queries per second but what
does it not provide it does not provide
you global ipv4 and ipv6 load balancing
you cannot route on the basis of layer
seven headers and you cannot do SSL
proxy so Google needed to come up with a
global load balancer now just to recap
think of traditional load balancers in
public clouds they are regional they
have a regional wipey address and a
regional set of back-end instances so
let's say you have a service that are
distributed in three different regions
you have three different VIPs now if you
wanted to globally live load bounced
across those three regions you need a
DNS load balancer that would map the
client request to one of these bits but
there are several challenges with this
approach imagine an instance in one of
the regions going away the load
balancing and the DNS infrastructure has
to know of that change let's say your
client caches that IP address and that
would result in a suboptimal selection
last your capacity is siloed resources
in one region cannot be used in another
region
now that would simply just not work for
Google so when we had to come up with a
load balancer we did not use the DNS
based approach what we did was we went
and pushed the load balancing to the
edge of our global network and we came
up with a single global anycast
virtual IP address that front-ends
worldwide capacity if you run into
availability or capacity constraints you
can do cross region failover
and fallback it's very nicely tied to
our auto scaling infrastructure so when
demand rises we can scale it up to meet
our requirements and when demand herbs
we can scale it down it's also really
nice gives you this single point where
you can apply global policies and it's
very very performant because there's
nearly no single point instance that's
doing the load balancing and you can
support easily a million queries per
second so how do our customers typically
deploy this right you would typically
actually start out deploying your
services in a single region but what you
would do is you'd configure a global
falling rule with the global anycast
virtual IP address and you'd make your
customer Maya in California very happy
but let's say you're you know your
service grows in popularity and now you
have a customer Bob in New York that
also wishes to access the service
similarly you deploy a back-end
instances in u.s. East but you don't
have to reconfigure the VIP you don't
have to modify any DNS entries you're a
global success you have customers in
Asia that are now using back-end
instances in Singapore unfortunately
certain in sudden happened and you had
instances and Singapore go down at the
same time demand in US West spiked and
you need to address those events what
will happen is without requiring any
intervention your user requests will
seamlessly be directed to the region
with the most available capacity now
when the us best skills up the traffic
will again fall back to us West again
this is happening all seamlessly without
any intervention now what is it under
the hood this too is also software based
load balancing the load balancing
happens at these things called Google
front-end engines our G FES these G FES
are located at the edges of our network
now the edge itself is teared some of
the load balancing happens in the tier
one edge some of the load balancing
happens in the tier two the Tier one
edge is where a points of presence are
located the GF is effectively proxy the
client traffic and the load balance by
working in concert with each other
working with our Software Defined
Networking plane and also our global
control and config plane how do we
distribute traffic now this slide is
really dense but I have one key takeaway
which is as long as you have capacity in
the region closest to your users we will
send the traffic there but should you
run into capacity or availability
constraints we will then direct the
traffic spill over to the next closest
region we call this our waterfall model
for load balancing a region has multiple
zones we will populate each zone
proportional to the capacity that you've
allocated to each zone and each zone we
will load balance evenly among the
instances in a round robin fashion now
it's quite a lot and I don't expect you
to remember this all is going to show
this to your life but before we go to
the demo I think it's important that we
cover what the data model for our
configuration looks like right and the
load balancing you have something called
front-end and you have something called
a back-end in the front-end you have
that global anycast VIP that VIP is
associated with a forwarding rule that
forwarding rule points to a target proxy
now this target proxy could be HTTP
HTTPS TCP or SSL
the target proxy is also the location
where you have URL maps and URL map
essentially maps in our client URL based
on host and path rules to a specific
back-end service now this is where the
backend portion begins a back-end
service is made off of backends a
backends could be managed instance
groups or network endpoint groups the
backend service is also the location
where we associate health configuration
and serving capacity also it's going to
show all of this to you right now so now
let me just hand it off to AWS to show
this to all to your life thanks Bobby so
can we switch to the demo please all
right so here what we have we have on
the screen there are three load
balancers that I have configured three
HTTP Lopez load balancers I'm going to
talk the first two we're not going to
cover and this name will be the next one
so let's drill down in the take a look
at the third one so the third little
balancer what I have configured here and
let's see now how that data model that
Bobby explained how it maps to configure
in it so the first part is the front-end
so as you can see here here on the
screen I have exposed both VIPs one
before and another one v6 and remember
that these are global VIPs so
irrespective of your client location
it's going to target the same either
before or v6 and they're both exposed
exposed on the using HTTP which is part
of our best practices I mean TLS
everywhere so that's the first session
that is established between the client
and the VIP then I have also added here
have configured a feature that is
available as beta which is the Google
mannered manage search so we are going
to take care of that for you and do the
renewal and revocation of the search and
we'll see that in detail also with the
SSL policy and the last config of the
front-end is the network tier what we
have here is the premium tier that Bobby
touched which means the cool potato type
of strategy which is the packet stays
within our
as much as possible so it's not handed
off to the internet so it traverses over
our backbone now the second section is
the host and path rules what I have
defined two simple rules here so the
first one or the last one better saying
is based on the URL everything that is
being sent to slash secure slash is
going to be sent to one back-end and
everything else the default path then is
going to send is going to be sent to a
separate back end and less here is how
do we map those host and path rules to
the back end so I have two back ends
here in this case the first one which is
Matt which is going to be to handle all
the default traffic I have configured as
the endpoint protocol HTTP which again
is also our best practice so make sure
that we recommend having TLS everywhere
so the first session just to recap
between the client and the VIP uses HTTP
the second one for this back end also
relies on HTTPS I have also a name port
which is a port that you can define for
the communication between the proxy
layer and the client it doesn't have to
be the same one as the front end and
we're going to see that configuration as
well when we take a look at the manage
things let's group the next one is a
timeout which is for the call so for the
connection between the proxy and the
backend so here you want to take a look
at your application requirements so if
you have any requirements of using
long-lived sessions you may want to
relax that that timer a little bit in
order to not kill your sessions before
before you you want cloud CDN is also
here you can enable cloud CDN on the
backend level and it's a it's a very
simple configuration it's a checkbox to
enable cloud CDN and just a note here
that cloud CDN can use a VM as a
back-end service but also a bucket so
you could also do CDN on a bucket and
that traffic is going those that
cashable content is going to be cached
also at the pop layer right so right at
the edge also another configuration that
we have there is the health track
which is how what is the mechanism that
is going to be used to check the
liveliness of that instance in this case
I'm using here HTTPS but you could also
configure using HTTP using HTTP to
configure the timers and do some other
customizations like setting for example
what type of response would you would
expect from our application to consider
that healthy now we have also as part of
the back end session affinity so I have
cookie here and but could also be
configured as client IP so client IP
would mean that all the sessions from
certain IP will be sent to that back-end
right to maintain the affinity cookie on
the other hand will allow the register
the HTTP load balancer will send a
cookie back to the client so if you have
multiple sessions from the same client
they it would be allowed a better
distribution across our backends I have
also here the connection training
timeout which is the timer that you
configure in this case the default for
the sessions to persist or just to live
in that instance when an instance is
removed from the backend so you want to
configure that as well to make sure that
when you remove the session from the
group or sorry when you remove an
instance from the group those sessions
are not killed automatically and last
but not least here I'm using also a new
feature have configured which is
available in beta which is user-defined
headers so let me magnify here so I have
configured this custom request headers
that can be added on the HTTP layer on
the on the proxy layer and sent back to
your back-end in this case imagine here
that those options client region C D RT
T so the backends can take a look at
that information on a per session basis
and make smarter decisions but it's
better if I show you how that looks like
in the web page so I have configured
this is the landing page for that web
and here you can see some of the
information that I mentioned so the
first one is the client IP which is the
public IP that my client is using
probably unneeded IP in this case
the second one is load balancer IP which
is the VIP that's the same one that we
saw in the configuration the third one
is the proxy IP which is for the second
session what's going to be the source IP
of that second session the server
information and here you can see the
user-defined headers that I inserted so
my connection is coming from San
Francisco so I would be a little bit
alarmed if we was coming from a
different place
here's my RTT in this case three
milliseconds the lat/long the TLS
version and ciphers so this is custom
custom I mean you don't need to add all
the other variables but if you want to
add some of them that's how you do it
now going back here just what you show
also the second back-end that I've I
have configured we are going to use it
for the network security demo but I do
own Lee thing that I want to highlight
is I'm using a different protocol here
so for this back-end I'm using HTTP 2
instead of HTTP which is also another
feature that is releasing data so for
the communication between the proxy
layer in the backend you can actually
leverage HTTP HTTP 2 for better latency
of your application let's take a look
then at the at the instance group at one
of those actually before we do that just
one thing that I wanted to explain make
sure it's clear is when you configure
those backends you add those instance
groups that could be managed or
unmanaged as Bobbi explained on those
instance groups you have the option to
set the capacity so what we can see here
on the right side
so if we go back there so what we can
see here is the max RPS that I have
configured in this case the way it works
is I all configure on the on the manage
instance group basis the amount of
requests that each VM can handle in this
case 100 RPS requests per second and
then the max capacity that that VM can
handle in this case 100% now if I
combine those two it means every each VM
can handle 100 RPS and if I set that
with the auto scaling it means that on
the 80% of that capacity a TRPs I'll
scale up and started and start a new a
new instance also note that in the
second instance group that I have
defined here our scaling is off and I
have set that to a capacity of 10% so
this is a great use case you use for
canary deployments so if you have a new
web server that you want to deploy and
just say you can just send just a small
fraction of your traffic you can do that
and have a new instance group just using
part of that of the just getting a
handling part of that traffic and
they're going to see that in action but
just before we do that just wanted to
show you very quickly the load belt the
instance group configuration so the
first part is the name port that I
mentioned in this case I'm using 443
encrypted traffic but you could also use
a different port if you wanted then the
next one is the instance template which
what is the instance that is being used
here to create that VM so you can
customize that a lot with your your own
software and the required software that
you need auto scaling is on as we
mentioned and I just wanted to highlight
the cooldown period which is the time
that you need to make sure that your
application takes to be ready to process
traffic so in these cases I change to 30
seconds because it's a simple web server
but you may want to customize according
to your application requirements and the
last one is Auto healing so you can
enable auto healing on the group here
because it's going what it's going to do
is health check that instance based on
the criteria that you set and you get
also another timer now just note that
with the auto healing if for some reason
that instance is marked as unhealthy
it's going to be destroyed and recreated
so it will take more time than as
compared to just pulling an instance
from the group now I'm also selling
traffic here so let's take just a quick
look at how the monitoring works in this
case so I have three different low
generators one in Asia and other one in
North America another one in Europe they
are sending traffic here and you can see
that for that for the European one the
traffic the target is the back end that
is you know in Europe because it's close
and since I'm sending a little bit below
200 RP s which is the max I can see here
that is being alerted that usages
approach approaching capacity now
another behavior that we can see here
also is traffic being spilled over from
the Asian and North American load
generators being sent to another to my
new instance group just a small fraction
of that traffic just like I want it
because I just wanted ten percent of the
traffic being sent there and now so
another thing that I want to wanted to
show you is I have created this is mark
there's a new dashboard here showing
also the protocol distribution so this
is based on a new feature that is
available in alpha which is the login
and monitoring of the HTTP load balancer
so we are going to talk a little bit
more about what is available but we can
see here the number of requests being
generated by my load generators the same
ones that you that you saw and how the
how is the protocol distribution so each
one of those is sending is using a
different HTTP version now back to Bobby
so some of you have internal services
that you run on Google Cloud you want to
scale and grow them behind a virtual IP
address that's only accessible from your
internal instances and for these use
cases we have the internal load balancer
so for the
for internal load balancer you're
effectively load balancing behind an RFC
1918 private virtual IP address you are
load balancing TCP and UDP similar to
your network load balancer and you know
doing the two three or five tuple
hashing your client IP is preserved and
you can have TCP HTTP or HTTPS health
checks now the key takeaway is this
there's really no middle proxy
effectively there's really no load
balancer the way it works is we have our
underlying software-defined networking
layer Andromeda that takes care of doing
the connection tracking the consistent
hashing and what it does is it sends
traffic directly from the client VM to
the back-end that's how the client IP is
preserved but what's even more important
to note is that this is a very scale out
architecture because there is no choke
point you can have a very performant
load balancer if you look the data model
seems vaguely familiar yes it is pretty
consistent with our global data model
except over here the forwarding rule
which is regional forwarding rule as
opposed to a global falling rule as an
RFC 1918 VIP you specify the protocol
TCP IP I mean TCP or UDP and then you
can have up to five ports and it points
directly to a regional back-end service
now one thing we went and did this year
is to give you the flexibility to
specify all ports now think of use cases
such as a pivotal Cloud Foundry where
they have multiple applications each on
a separate TCP port well you can load
balance them with really good entropy
behind a single load balancer as opposed
to creating you know foreign rules for
different ports you can have firewall
rules to protect access to ports that
you don't want traffic on now a lot of
our customers also have requirements for
running certain applications in active
standby mode and I'm happy to announce
that we just did a beta for something we
call our failover groups and what it
allows you to do is you can designate
certain instance groups as primary and
certain instance groups as
secondary when the health of the
instances in the primary group grow
below a certain threshold the load
balancer will just automatically
failover the traffic to the standby
instance group you know if it's in beta
we love for you to try it out give your
feedback and we can go from there
now you know in my initial slide I
mentioned five load balancers deep-dive
there was a six load balancer in there
we do have a layer seven internal load
balancer it is an alpha it does support
both compute as well as kubernetes
container based kubernetes under the
hood it uses the Envoy based side car
proxy that's you know performant
feature-rich as well as open source you
don't have to worry about the management
of it because GCP Google Cloud manages
the the load balancer for you it's
currently a regional service but making
it globally available is something on
our roadmap so now I'm gonna hand it
over to AHS to talk about container
native load balancing thanks I get about
me so now we're going to talk a little
bit about the network endpoint groups
that are they're used or leveraged by
the container native load balancing so
on the left side here the blue one what
we have is the traditional way to load
balance across kubernetes clusters which
would be targeting the nodes so in that
case the instance group would have or
the load balancer have the visibility of
two different nodes only and doesn't
know about the pods so it would load
balance and distribute the traffic
across those different nodes only when
the traffic gets to those nodes then
queue proxy that will be running on that
node then we'll use if needed
IP masquerade to do source net and send
and may send that traffic to a different
node to a different pod that different
node maybe on a different zone so you
may have internal communication in that
case so in for this behavior then you
have two different things that apply
here the first one is the source net so
you don't have the source client anymore
because it's doing its applying source
net and the second one you have a
your network utilization because now you
have IP tables being applied and traffic
that gets to one part to unload being
sent to another node to a different part
there now we introduced the network in
point groups concept which is also
available in in beta so the network end
point groups concept the load balancer
will now have visibility to the pod
layer to the pod level by using IP and
IP and port pairs so in this example
here instead of targeting two different
nodes you will target five different
pods so you have better latency you can
expect better latency better network
utilization because we don't have
traffic getting to one node and then
being translated to a different one and
also better health tracking because
instead of health tracking the node then
then gets translated you just health
track the pods directly so and that is
also available by adding that annotation
that I added here to the screen but
let's see this live so can we go back to
the demo please thank you so I have
created two different clusters in this
case identical clusters so which one of
them with three nodes and six pods and
six spots and then I have exposed both
of them using ingress and that and one
of them with the networking point groups
annotation as I mentioned and just to
make sure that we know how the pods are
distributed here if we use this command
the Skip color command then we can see
that kubernetes then allocated those
those pods across different nodes a
little bit differently so if we take a
look at the networking point group the
NAG cluster then the pods got our look
allocated three pods in one node then
two in the second one and one in the
third one and the non Nags was a little
bit different because it got what four
pods in one node and then one in each
additional node now I am also sending
traffic here have traffic generators so
if we go back to my load to the load
balancer
let's see how this traffic is being
distributed so first let's take a look
at
non lag one so the first thing is the
instance groups so it sees three
different instance groups and that's it
I mean just just have no awareness now
if you go to monitoring I'm sending
around fifty five hundred requests per
second and since it does not have
visibility into the number of nodes
those requests are just evenly
distributed across the nodes
irrespective of the number of pods there
are healthy there now if you take a look
at the NAG one since the neg she's a
load balancer now has visibility into
the pods then we can see that the
traffic is actually distributed
according to the number of pods there so
the first node is getting traffic here
for around 1200 requests per second the
second one is getting three times dead
and the third one two times that now if
we take a look also at our custom
dashboard that I also built using the
the same login and monitoring feature
that is available in alpha we can see
the number of requests they are reaching
and also the latency and break the
latency based on the first session in
the second session so we can see here
that even though the same number of the
same amount of resources are dedicated
to both clusters the Negin abled one is
able to handle 7,000 requests so two
thousand more that that no neg one and
in terms of latency what this graph here
means is on the 99th percentile or all
sessions under 99% of the sessions for
the neg one it took around 57
milliseconds here we magnify so 50
second 57 milliseconds now the no nag
took 106 milliseconds in in terms of
latency so it's almost took almost twice
the amount of time to respond to those
sessions and just to make sure that
there are no tricks so I have also added
here the the front-end latency so it's
not significant so the latency is really
on the back
and also just to highlight the point
that I mentioned in terms of network
traffic even though it's a very simple
web server that I have running here the
NAG one consumes half of the of the
amount of traffic as compared to the to
the non nag so if you had those nodes
just like in this case across different
zones you would be paying for more
traffic as well to cross those zones
back to Bobby
so now you've built a service and it's
now very important that you secure your
edge to protect it against DDoS attacks
either volumetric or application layer
before we get started right everything
at work security at Google cloud it's a
shared responsibility between you and
Google we strive our best to protect our
network as much as possible but we also
give you tools to protect it we give you
tools and our best practice that we
recommend is take a defense in-depth
approach secure it at all layers so
please secure it within your V PC in
your V PC access to your V PC access to
Google services from your V PC and
secure your edge we're going to talk
about securing your edge soon but a lot
of these individual topics have very
good coverage in sessions here at next
and I would strongly recommend that you
go take them out and do your due
diligence in terms of figuring out the
best security solution for your
requirements now at Google we strongly
recommend as a best practice that you
run TLS everywhere that you can this is
for your data privacy and your data
integrity so we don't charge extra for
encrypted versus unencrypted traffic we
give you HTTPS and SSL proxies we will
talk about our manage suits that help
you apply certs to talk to your clients
we also recommend that you can apply
self-signed cert from your back-end
instances to your load balancer so
net-net
as this diagram illustrates have HTTP
Els running everywhere and you know have
better privacy and data integrity if you
want to run multiple domains behind a
single virtual IP address and port of
the load balancer we support that manage
certs we will help you reduce your toil
of procuring the suit and managing the
lifecycle of the suit all you have to do
as this slide illustrates is just
specify the domain that you want to
secure and Google will procure the show
the certificate in very short order and
keep you up and running you can use SSL
policies to specify the minimum TLS
version and the SSL features that you
want to enable on your HTTPS load
balancer and your SSL proxies you can
you can use Google pre-configured
profile for some of these features or
you can choose to have your own custom
let's say you have a strict requirement
where you want to be very explicit in
the ciphers and the TLS version that you
want to deploy in your network you can
use custom SSL policies for that now
securing your edge and again take a
layered approach use a global load
balancer use it in concert with cloud
armor use it in concert with identity
aware proxy and layer it with firewall
rules so with the Google global network
and our global load balancer we are able
to absorb mitigate and you know
dissipate a lot of the volumetric layer
3 and layer 4 attacks so that you get
with a global load balancer now for
application layer attacks we recommend
that you take a look at a cloud armor
solution there's actually a lot of
really good talks over here at next a
cloud armour but essentially with cloud
armor you can specify security policies
such as IP allowed delay denialists and
geo based access control in addition to
protecting protection against cross-site
scripting or SQL injection attacks now
layer that with identity or our proxy
now this is the whole beyond carp story
so based on the identity and context of
the user you can authenticate
the user and authorize their access to
back-end services so layering security
levels on top and all of this work in
concert with each other so if your
identity aware proxy says no and your
cloud armor says yes it'll default to no
in addition because our load balancer
proxies come from very well defined IP
addresses
why don't you block you know your
firewall should be configured to only
allow those traffic from the load
balancer don't open it up to the
Internet so take a defense in-depth
approach apply multiple solutions that
we provide for you and protect your edge
I'm gonna give it all to us to kind of
show all of this in action thanks Bobby
so here I'm going to show a little bit
of the security features that I have
configured
some of them actually showed already so
the first one is the manage search the
Google manage search that I have enabled
here so as we can see it's it's active
and it's a super simple feature to
deploy the way to configure it is you
have to enable in your DNS and then once
you do that make sure that you add the a
record the quad a record pointing to
your VIPs and those whips are configured
pointing to your fording to our back
ends and are healthy once you do that
then the the search should be should
take a few minutes just to be alive and
ready I have also attached here an SSL
policy restricting the TLS version so
let's take a look how that is actually
working
so I have my default policy and I have
to find a new one which restricts the
minimum TLS version - 1 . you and the
set of ciphers - are restricted so if we
actually add it here
we could even select a custom list and
select only the ciphers that I want so
I'm exposing that here on my on my VIP
and this is attached to the back end to
the front end now if we go here to my
cloud shell and I try to connect using
TLS 1.2 we can see that HTTP 2 responded
with a 200 it was fine now if I change
to 1.1 then I get an error of not not
being accepted and the last part that I
wanted to show you here is cloud armor
in this case I'm using cloud armor with
the allow it and I lists so basically
what I'm doing is setting the default
behavior magnifying so setting the
default behavior to deny and I'm
customizing the response in this case of
403 but could be also a different
response would be a 502 for example and
then I'm setting a analyst in this case
setting here the the ranges from from
the most cone so everyone connected can
can actually reach there's this VIP and
I then I'm targeting that second
backhand that I have configured so
everything that goes to this lash secure
slash is where I'm attaching it so if I
go to my landing page and just type
secure you can see it's a different
landing page and now if I try from cloud
share I get a 403 so it's being blocked
so now you've secured your reg edge and
deployed your services the next thought
that comes to your mind is how do i
optimize my services and you'd like to
optimize them for latency and then
optimize them for cost we've already
talked about our distributed edge
infrastructure and the latency benefits
that you get out of that a few
additional takeaways when you do SSL
termination at the edge you get better
latency when you have TCP
retransmissions from the edge you get
much better latency performance talking
about TCP optimizations after the first
connection is established from the
Google front end to the server we can
then optimize for subsequent connections
the round-trip latency is we can
eliminate most of those round-trip times
and optimized for handshake latency now
a really nice way to optimize for
latency especially if you have content
that's cacheable is cache it at the edge
use cloud CDN all you have to do is
enable a checkbox on your back-end
service and you'll be serving content
and delighting your users with their
latency experience in fact there was a
public study done by said access comm
that compared Google Cloud CDN with
other providers you can go refer that
link and it showed that Google Cloud CDN
had lower latency better throughput and
much better availability how do you make
the web faster now this is something we
at Google spend a lot of time working on
and thinking about and if we have any my
two takeaways from this session this
please go take a look at quick take a
look at HTV two and see if it can help
provide your latency benefits so quick
quick stands for quick UDP internet
connections if you've used Chrome or
you've used YouTube your traffic has
gone on top of quic quick is UDP based
transport that's encrypted and it's
optimized for HTTP among its many
features the three that help improve
latency are quicker connection setup
times multiplexing of different
dreams and no head-of-line blocking so
when said exes was doing the study of CD
and throughput when we went and turned
on quick the throughput increased
significantly
that was because with lower latency we
were able to set up more connections and
with more connections we were able to
get a higher throughput now the diagram
on the right shows the advantages that
quick has in terms of quicker connection
set up times when you think of HTTP
running over TCP and TLS consider all
the handshakes that are involved with
that HTTP over TCP and TLS and think how
with quick it's a lot quicker it's even
more quicker if the server's been seen
before when the latency is just zero we
also support HTTP - not just from the
client to the load balancer but also
from the load balancer to the backend
doing this enables us to support G RPC
and what it enables us to do is support
a stream based load balancing of G RPC
streams to the back-end service now
optimizing for cost you know when you
egress the data center you incur egress
bandwidth charges but if you're
optimizing for performance we recommend
that your return traffic do take the
googles you know performance and well
provision network and exited at the
closest point of presence to the user to
give the best user experience but let's
say you have certain workloads that are
cost sensitive they are not
mission-critical and you want to
optimize for cost
well we then give you the option of the
standard here and with the standard here
it'll take standard ISP transit to
egress the data center just like other
cloud providers and you'll save and cost
savings you can turn it on per load
balancer or you can turn it on per
project and user defined headers so also
I had shown a really cool demo of this
so what you can do is add the load
balancer level you can configure
custom request headers to be added to
those requests you can configure for
collecting the geolocation the TLS
parameters the smooth round-trip latency
between the load balancer and the client
capture all that information from the
load balancer send it to your back-end
instance then the application logic in
the backend can use that information and
then use it for the optimization
purposes that you are looking for so now
I'm going to request all to pull it all
together for this session
thanks Bobby so just to summarize a
little bit of the best practices that we
have the first point is how to pick the
right load balancer for you we have this
chart which is available in our public
site but some of the main points that I
would highlight here is make sure you
understand what type of traffic you want
external versus internal what type of
client v6 versus before what type of
protocol do you have HTTP HTTP do you
need host and path rules
is it TCP is it UDP how the sessions are
being distributed do you need TLS
termination so this helps you to pick
the best load balancer for your use case
now once you have selected that a few
points that I wanted to highlight is the
first one is secure service right so we
have seen several of the best practices
here in the demo and also we talked
through it so TLS everywhere that's the
first point
so do TLS on your front-end using your
cert or it leveraging the Google manage
cert so I don't have to be concerned
about renewals use self-signed cert
certs for example on your instances for
that communication between the proxy and
the VIP leverage the VPC viral so as
Bobbi mentioned make sure you harden
your VPC file it does not allow and do
not allow traffic that we're not
supposed to expect use the SSL policies
as well very important for for
compliance so optimize for latency so
pick the right regions closer to your
clients leverage the browser's region
load balancer devote the global load
balancer so
make use of the the waterfall algorithm
that it's going to just send the traffic
to the closest available region based on
the RTT if you're using kubernetes take
a look at the container native load
balancing for the network endpoint
groups because that that may also help
you with latency also optimize for auto
scaling our load balancers they don't
need to be warmed up right they are
ready to process traffic however your
back-end instances they need to be ready
so make sure that you configure those
those instances with the right or
scaling criteria that you need the
timers that you need for that instance
to be ready and be careful also with
health checks they can be cherry and the
way that the architecture works is that
there is a back-end manager there is
responsible for doing all those health
checks so you can set those timers and
and customize those timers based on your
application requirements and another
thing is auto healing it is it it is an
option that you can you can use just be
aware that if auto healing the text that
your application is not ready it's going
to destroy that that VM and recreate so
it would take a longer time if you are
using the the global load balancers HTTP
load balancers TCP or SSL proxy so
combine that with the cloud arm with
cloud bomber being allowing the
nihilists or at the waffler
for all the other features that Bobbi
mentioned I also use the capacity scaler
so we talked about it right so the
capacity you can set for percentage a
small percentage so when you have a new
version you can then deploy with just
that instance group and just and just as
more percentage just to test traffic and
by the way it don't need it doesn't need
to be in the same V PC so that it can
also be on a separate V PC set the
appropriate connection timeouts
so make sure you understand your
application what we expect how long
those those flows they need to be to be
up and running and use cookies or
ip-based as we talked now for the layer
4 load balancer and network load
balancer the default is the 5 tuple so
you can get a better distribution
however in some cases you may have a
fragmented packet or even sessions that
you need
to do stickiness based on on the source
and client IP so you can customize that
also on the Isle B Bobby mentioned that
the IRB actually does not exist so the
way it works in the the architecture
under the hood is that those instances
they are configured to respond to
packets sent to the VIP so if you're
using your custom VM that's that's a
common thing make sure that you add that
to your VM as well and allow that VM to
respond to packets sent to the VIP I
think we're actually at the close of
session but before we go please take a
moment to say a big thanks to the
production crew they were awesome they
did they work really hard and I totally
appreciate their work
[Music]